وتعليقا مشاهدينا على قضيه ترامب الاخيره
تجاوز عدد الجمهوريين الخلافات عدد منهم
الخلافات طبعا مع ترامب نائب الرئيس
السابق مايك بانس الذي انتقلت ترامب سابقا
وقف بجانبه وقال ان الامريكيين لا يريدون
رؤيه شامبو
وانتقد قرار المدعي العام في المنهات ورغم
انه لم يقدم الدعم لكن تعهد بان مكتبه لن
يتدخل في تسليم ترامب الى نيويورك لكن هذا
لم يمنع دي لسنتس من محاوله استغلال
الازمه حيث سخر من الموقف الذي وضع فيه
ترامب نفسه
لا اعرف ما الذي يمكن ان يدفع لتقديم
اموال لنجمه اباحيه لتامين الصمت بشان نوع
من العلاقات المزعومه لا استطيع التحدث عن
ذلك ما يمكن لقوله انه اذا كان لديك مدعي
عام يتجاهل الجرائم التي تحدث كل يوم في
نطاق سلطته القضائيه واختار العوده الى
سنوات مضت لمحاوله استخدام شيء ما حول
مدفوعات الاموال التي يتم دفعها لنجوم
الافلام الاباحيه فهذا مثال على اتباع
اجنده سياسيه اعتقد ان هذا خطا جوهري